foreign
the original creation of the turtles
came out of love passion in a late night
out of goofiness
I did this drawing of a turtle standing
upright with a mask on nunchucks wrapped
his arms and I put it on a piece desk
and they said this is going to be the
next big thing a Ninja Turtle
[Music]
the series came out in 1987 when I was
five years old the live action movie
came out in 1990 I was eight it was like
perfectly geared towards someone my age
Ninja Turtles is something that all of
us have been obsessed with ever since we
were kids I remember being four years
old and wanting all of the toys action
figures cartoons the bed sheets I was
just kind of obsessed with them I
started taking karate probably because
of the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles how
much love was put into their designs and
their props my dad bought me nunchucks
because of the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles package art and everything about
it was like funny and weird and told a
story
they called us and said would you guys
ever be interested in working on the
Ninja Turtles did we play it cool at all
or no no no
if we can approach it through this
teenage lens
really lean into like a coming-of-age
version of it and they said yes like a
brother Jeff was willing to say like we
have to make this look and feel totally
different he was like What if it's
animated by teenagers so to speak we put
so much work into the visuals into the
artwork the style is perfect for this
it's almost like an underground comic it
reminds me a lot of the original stuff
that Peter and I did
it's you and your buddies it's you and
your brothers it's you and your sister
and your brother I think a lot of people
can relate to kind of feeling like an
outsider at times
this desire to fit in to be accepted
it's one of the most essential emotions
the fans are insanely awesome whether it
be I love the turtle so much I wore the
same Halloween costume for three years
in a row or I had a really tough
childhood and the turtles helped me get
through that and that's when it hits you
emotionally
wanting to create wanting to tell your
own stories and then actually having it
happen it's a dream and it happened I
love the Ninja Turtles it was like the
first thing I was ever a fan of it's fun
and exciting
here I am 61 years old and I'm still
getting up and drawing Comics Turtles
every day
[Music]
foreign